Salut, ici Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour. Après un petit mois de silence, désolé, je suis vraiment débordé en ce moment, Septante Minutes Avec est de retour et on parle aujourd'hui avec le sociologue David Paternotte des campagnes anti-genre.
Donc autrement dit, ces mouvements conservateurs qui réagissent de manière très violente, de manière ferme et épidermique à l'émancipation des femmes et des minorités sexuelles.
Vous entendrez pourquoi il choisit d'appeler ça les campagnes anti-genre dans un instant, mais grosso modo, on met là-dedans les choses comme l'Alliance Vita, la Manif pour tous, la notion d'un soi-disant lobby LGBT et tout ça et tout ça.
Je précise que pour la première fois, on a enregistré cet épisode en portant nos masques, raison pour laquelle vous entendrez que ma voix est un petit peu étouffée comme Kenny dans South Park.
Bonne nouvelle, il y a d'autres épisodes en préparation. On en reparle juste après l'interview. Bonne écoute. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec David Paternotte. Bonjour David.
Bonjour.
Vous êtes sociologue à l'Université libre de Bruxelles et vous travaillez principalement sur les questions de genre et de sexualité.
Donc on va discuter ensemble de ces questions-là et aussi de leurs opposants, c'est-à-dire les mouvements masculinistes, voilà, réactionnaires, populistes.
Première question, c'est : qu'est-ce qui vous a amené sur les questions de genre et de masculinisme et ainsi de suite ?
La première étape, donc en général, on étudie, tout le monde étudie, même si parfois les personnes essayent de l'escamoter, on étudie des questions qui nous parlent pour des raisons diverses et variées.
Donc dans mon cas, voilà, en étant étudiant de master d'abord, j'avais travaillé sur les mobilisations autour de l'ouverture du mariage aux couples de même sexe.
Donc ça, on était dans le début des années 2000. Débat qui était à l'époque, comment dire, qui était à l'époque en discussion, en cours.
Et par ailleurs, voilà, en tant qu'homme gay, c'était un débat qui me parlait. Donc c'est ce qui m'a amené dans ces questions-là.
Par ailleurs, y avait à l'époque à peu près personne qui travaillait sur les questions LGBT dans l'université en Belgique.
Et comme dans d'autres pays, mais en Belgique, c'est particulièrement vrai, c'est dans le champ des études féministes et des études de genre que ces travaux ont pu être accueillis.
Donc c'est comme ça aussi que je me suis développé au sein des études de genre en Belgique. Et à partir de là, j'ai travaillé la thèse aussi sur la revendication de l'ouverture du mariage en Belgique, en France, en Espagne.
J'ai travaillé pendant pas mal de temps sur les militantismes LGBT, les militantismes féministes. Et après, comme beaucoup d'autres collègues, en fait,
on s'est retrouvés face à des manifestations conservatrices une décennie plus tard, dans les années 2010.
Dans mon cas, c'est autour de la Manif pour tous et c'est notamment suite à la demande de journalistes que je me suis retrouvé à travailler là-dessus.
C'est-à-dire quand la Manif pour tous a surgi dans le paysage médiatique français, y avait une demande d'expertise d'acteurs que personne n'avait suivi, pas vraiment moi non plus.
Donc, je me suis mis à les suivre pour pouvoir répondre aux sollicitations sur ce qui se passait. Et
c'est là où, avec d'autres collègues qui vivaient exactement la même chose dans d'autres pays, on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait quelque chose de beaucoup plus important et qu'on a commencé à lancer
des activités scientifiques.
Donc, on a notamment fait en 2014 avec plusieurs collègues à l'ULB le colloque Habemus Gender, qui était une bouteille lancée à la mer pour essayer de comprendre ce que c'était que ces manifestations contre le genre.
Y a eu beaucoup plus de réponses que prévu, donc on a dû doubler les panels, etc.
Et après, avec un autre collègue en Slovénie, on a commencé
à réfléchir aussi de manière internationale aux campagnes anti-genre parce qu'on voyait le même type de mobilisation comme la Manif pour tous, pour lui en Slovénie et en Croatie, mais aussi dans plein d'autres pays en Europe.
Donc c'est comme ça qu'il y a eu un retournement d'une certaine manière, de passer des gens qui défendent l'égalité de genre, la liberté sexuelle aux gens qui la refusent.
Vous êtes a priori un homme. Quel impact ça a sur la nature de votre travail ? Est-ce que de ce fait, on remet en question votre légitimité à travailler sur certaines questions ?
Est-ce que, inversement, vous ressentez un privilège vis-à-vis de vos collègues femmes ? Puisqu'on sait, par exemple, que les universitaires féministes ont souvent été remises en question en disant : « Mais
vous n'êtes pas neutre, vous ne pouvez pas travailler sur ces questions.
Vous êtes directement impactée », alors que les hommes tout autant impactés n'étaient pas du tout remis en question.
Est-ce que vous ressentez un impact vis-à-vis de votre passif d'homme ?
Alors, ça dépend si on ramène juste à la question d'homme ou si on élargit à d'autres questions, par exemple en termes de sexualité, qui sont en partie aussi les questions qui m'ont amené à travailler sur le genre.
Donc je dirais, après, la neutralité n'existe jamais. Donc croire qu'il y a un savoir neutre, c'est une illusion. On parle toujours de quelque part, donc c'est toutes les théories féministes sur le point de vue, la positionnalité,
et c'est quelque chose à prendre en compte quand on parle ou aussi en fonction de ce qu'on dit.
Après, dans le travail scientifique et particulièrement en sciences sociales, on appartient rarement, enfin parfois ça arrive, mais à la catégorie à laquelle on appartient.
Ou si on prend les gens en histoire, ben fatalement, ce sont des personnes qui étudient souvent des personnes déjà décédées, des personnes d'un passé parfois lointain.
Donc la question, c'est plutôt la question des méthodologies à partir desquelles on travaille pour réfléchir à ce qu'on dit et comment on le dit.
Et par exemple, de ne pas parler, mais ça, normalement, si on fait le travail correctement, c'est de ne pas parler à la place d'autres personnes.
Par exemple, vous citiez, je travaille sur les mouvements conservateurs auxquels je n'appartiens pas.
Ça n'empêche pas de les étudier, mais en sachant qu'on parle pas du même point de vue, qu'on n'intervient pas nécessairement du même endroit.
Et donc c'est plutôt comment le savoir est produit qui est important.
On est tout à fait alignés à ce niveau-là. Simplement, je pense comprendre que
beaucoup n'ont pas saisi le fait que leur position d'objectivité n'était en fait pas une position objective et vont donc remettre en question l'approche de personnes qui auront une,
voilà, une démarche peut-être plus féministe parce qu'elle n'est pas assez neutre, soi-disant.
Est-ce que donc vous avez ressenti le fait qu'on vous donne plus ou moins de crédibilité ?
Non, ça, je pense pas que ça joue de manière importante. De nouveau, ça dépend ce sur quoi on doit intervenir.
Par exemple, il y a quelques années, la RTBF m'avait demandé de parler de culture du viol. Au début, j'avais dit : « Mais non, demandez plutôt à une femme, surtout pour intervenir dans les médias.
» Et là, la demande de journalistes féministes, c'était justement que ce soit un homme qui explique ce que c'est que la culture du viol, parce que ça leur paraissait que ça avait plus de poids.
Donc là, c'est un exemple où plutôt, ça avait donné plus de crédibilité. De nouveau, ça dépend dans les contextes.
On est aujourd'hui loin d'être les seuls hommes. C'est toujours une majorité de femmes, donc les hommes sont en minorité,
y compris ici dans l'équipe, dans le centre, y a une majorité de femmes, mais y a de plus en plus d'hommes qui travaillent sur des questions de genre aussi.
Par ailleurs, je voudrais aussi rappeler que les hommes ont un genre autant que les femmes, ce qui est souvent oublié, c'est-à-dire les hommes sont loin d'être neutres.
Donc c'est par exemple tous les travaux sur
la construction des masculinités qui peuvent tout autant être étudiés par des hommes que par des femmes, mais donc de ne pas oublier que les hommes n'incarnent pas le neutre, contrairement à ce qui a souvent été prétendu.
Alors, vous avez employé le terme de « campagne anti-genre ». Je propose qu'on prenne un instant pour définir un petit peu tous ces termes.
Est-ce que vous faites une différence entre campagne anti-genre, les mouvements anti-genre et ce qu'on appelle le masculinisme de manière plus générale ?
Est-ce que c'est la même chose ? Est-ce qu'il y a des nuances ?
Alors, c'est des choses différentes et une des questions de recherche, c'est de comprendre comment ça s'articule.
Et là, on n'est pas encore très très loin au niveau des articulations.
C'est-à-dire quand on a lancé le terme de campagne anti-genre, on cherchait surtout un terme pour définir de nouvelles formes de mobilisation contre
l'égalité de genre ou l'égalité sexuelle, c'est-à-dire d'essayer de saisir un moment qui se déroulait, qu'on voyait à l'œuvre, surtout à partir des années 2010.
Et donc l'idée campagne anti-genre fait spécifiquement référence à ça, avec de nouveaux discours, avec de nouvelles formes de mobilisation, une plus grande professionnalisation de ces mouvements, une plus grande transnationalisation.
Et au contraire, on voulait séparer
de réflexions plus larges. Par exemple, y a un certain nombre de collègues qui travaillent sur les antiféminismes ou sur les masculinismes, par exemple sur les antiféminismes, et qui ont parfois mis ces campagnes-là dans l'antiféminisme
en présentant ça comme le nouvel épisode d'une histoire beaucoup plus longue.
Ce qui est en partie vrai et en partie faux, je dirais. Effectivement, y a des liens, y a des liens d'acteurs,
mais ces collègues-là insistent beaucoup plus sur les continuités, alors que notre démarche était inverse.
C'était d'insister sur le moment de rupture en disant : « Attention, ce qu'on vit ici, c'est un changement qualitatif important par rapport à ce qui se faisait avant.
» Et on les a appelés anti-genre simplement parce que quand on creusait un petit peu les discours,
on se rend compte que, pour ces personnes, les différentes réformes qu'elles pouvaient combattre dans les pays, l'avortement, le mariage gay,
partenariat entre couples de même sexe, l'éducation sexuelle, les dispositifs contre la violence de genre, les études de genre, etc.,
c'était lié à ce qu'ils appelaient l'idéologie du genre ou la théorie du genre, plus souvent utilisée dans les pays francophones, c'est-à-dire l'idée qu'il y aurait à la fois un corpus qui
transforme fondamentalement la manière de faire famille, de faire couple et même d'être un individu, un individu sexué.
Et d'autre part, aussi une tentative de prise de pouvoir, une sorte de conspiration qui serait développée par les féministes, les gens qui font des études de genre, les militants LGBT, des institutions internationales.
Voilà, tout ça ensemble. Et c'est par rapport à ça qu'on les a simplement appelés. On se dit : « Bah, il faut un terme.
» Comme ces gens disent s'opposer à ce qu'ils et elles appellent le genre, et je dis ils et elles parce qu'il y a beaucoup de femmes dans ces mouvements-là, ce ne sont pas que des hommes, eh bien, on va les appeler anti-genre.
Alors après, on peut discuter. C'est un terme très descriptif. Le masculinisme, par exemple, n'est pas directement lié à ces mouvements-là.
Y a d'autres histoires qui amènent
ces mouvements masculinistes à se développer et qui sont vraiment liés à la remise en cause des masculinités, de la masculinité hégémonique ou ce qu'on pourrait appeler une masculinité plus traditionnelle dans beaucoup de sociétés,
sous l'impact des transformations sociales et aussi sous l'impact du féminisme
et de l'émancipation des femmes qui obligent tous les hommes à réinterroger leur manière d'être homme, c'est-à-dire les hommes ne peuvent plus être hommes de la même manière qu'il y a 50 ans, par exemple.
Et chez certains, ça provoque des réactions de rejet du féminisme, de rejet des femmes, de rejet du féminin et y compris dans un certain nombre de cas, de mobilisations actives contre,
par exemple, les droits des femmes, voire des cas de violence, violence qui peuvent parfois aller jusqu'à des assassinats, par exemple.
Mh. Alors, vous avez évoqué donc, dans le cadre des mouvements anti-genre, le caractère conspirationniste, le caractère de...
Voilà, cet élément de langage qui revient régulièrement, par exemple dans la bouche d'un Éric Zemmour en France, c'est le fameux lobby LGBT.
On sait pas très bien à quelle adresse il se situe, de qui il s'agit, mais voilà, c'est un ennemi qui revient souvent dans la bouche de ces personnalités-là.
Est-ce que le caractère conspirationniste est indissociable ? Est-ce qu'on le retrouve systématiquement dans ce mouvement anti-genre ?
En tout cas, il est central dans beaucoup de ces discours-là. C'est-à-dire, on va le retrouver dans le discours populiste qui n'est pas nécessairement la même chose que le discours anti-genre, mais de nouveau, y a des ponts.
On parlait du masculinisme, on va le retrouver aussi.
C'est l'idée qu'il y aurait des acteurs, en général minoritaires, ce qui fonctionne pour les personnes LGBT, fonctionne pas pour les femmes,
mais des personnes qui tireraient des fils de manière occulte pour essayer d'influencer les sociétés et avec l'idée d'influencer des bons citoyens ou monsieur et madame Tout-le-Monde ou monsieur et madame Normal.
Et on voit des figures qu'on retrouve. Par exemple, y a beaucoup d'antisémitisme dans ces débats-là.
On retrouve par exemple en Hongrie des campagnes qui étaient orchestrées par Viktor Orbán lui-même contre Soros, donc le milliardaire,
d'origine hongroise, juif, avec sa grande fondation, qui effectivement, Soros a financé énormément de mouvements féministes ou énormément de mouvements LGBT, notamment en Europe de l'Est et notamment en Hongrie,
mais donc était présenté sous la figure du Juif avec tout ce qu'on peut imaginer de clichés antisémites tirant les fils.
Et c'était vraiment des marionnettes et manipulant un certain nombre de personnages. Et donc ça renvoie des fondations puissantes derrière qui avanceraient leurs pions, par exemple.
L'autre élément qu'on voit beaucoup, c'est le rejet des institutions internationales. Donc le discours anti-genre est né avant tout en réponse aux grandes avancées aux Nations unies dans les années 90. Donc on a,
94, la conférence du Caire sur la population et le développement, où on va reconnaître les droits sexuels et reproductifs, c'est-à-dire qu'y a,
on a une catégorie juridique qui permet de reconnaître des choses comme le droit à la contraception ou l'avortement.
Et par ailleurs, en 95, c'est la conférence de Pékin sur les droits des femmes et on va avoir l'introduction du terme « genre » et après « gender mainstreaming » et des choses comme ça qui vont découler de ça.
Et ça va être vécu notamment par le Vatican qui va inventer le discours sur l'idéologie du genre. Et donc ça se développe dans toutes sortes de cénacles catholiques autour du Vatican comme une grande défaite.
Et donc il faut à la fois comprendre ce qui s'est passé.
Pourquoi est-ce que ça se passe à cause du genre ? C'est parce qu'à cette idéologie qu'ils n'avaient pas bien comprise, qu'ils ont perdu le terrain et qu'ils ont finalement perdu cette bataille-là aux Nations unies.
Et c'est aussi une stratégie. C'est-à-dire, on va essayer de discuter ce que c'est que le genre, de brouiller la signification pour monsieur et madame Tout-le-Monde, de mettre d'autres termes en discussion.
Donc c'est de là que ça vient. Et alors, sur le conspirationnisme, ce qui est important, c'est que de nouveau, c'est l'idée qu'y aurait un agenda des Nations unies.
Donc quelque chose qu'on voit dans beaucoup de productions, y a l'agenda du genre. C'est le nom d'un des premiers livres aux États-Unis qui est publié sur le sujet déjà en 1997.
C'est « The Gender Agenda ». Après, on aura « The Homosexual Agenda
». Et donc l'idée qu'y aurait des gens puissants qui, dans l'ombre, se sont saisis des institutions internationales pour imposer dans les États des choses dont les citoyens ne veulent pas.
Et une version moderne de ce conspirationnisme, c'est ce qu'on voit en Europe centrale orientale, notamment autour des combats, par exemple, entre l'Union européenne et la Hongrie ou la Pologne.
Cette idée que, par exemple, si on prend le cas polonais, l'Union européenne et les institutions européennes plus généralement, imposeraient la reconnaissance des droits LGBT ou de l'avortement à un peuple polonais qui n'en veut pas.
Et de nouveau, c'est cette idée que ces minorités malfaisantes auraient conquis des institutions internationales et arrivent à imposer au peuple polonais, via ces institutions, des choses dont le peuple ne veut pas.
Donc voilà, ça, c'est vraiment des figures conspirationnistes les plus courantes qu'on trouve.
Alors y a énormément de choses dans tout ce que vous avez expliqué. Je retiens principalement les axes que j'aimerais explorer.
Donc encore la question du conspirationnisme. Vous avez parlé aussi de l'aspect anti-système, voilà, contre les démocraties libérales qui existent chez nous en Occident.
Et aussi, voilà, l'importance de l'acteur qu'est le Vatican dans tout ça. Juste pour revenir donc sur le caractère complotiste de ce mouvement anti-genre, est-ce qu'on a remarqué une accélération
de ces idéologies anti-genre ces dix dernières années avec, voilà, la question des fake news, la question des réseaux sociaux ou,
voilà, cette info qui revient tout le temps comme quoi un mensonge circule beaucoup plus vite qu'une vérité.
Est-ce qu'on a remarqué une accélération ces 10, 20 dernières années ?
Oui, donc ça s'est vraiment accéléré, je pense, sous le poids de plusieurs facteurs. Donc y a d'abord un facteur de temps normal,
c'est-à-dire le temps que les acteurs historiquement liés au Vatican aient le temps de comprendre, d'élaborer un discours.
Donc ça a mis quelques années. Donc en gros, entre le milieu des années 90 et le milieu des années 2000, c'est le temps de préparation des arguments.
Milieu des années 2000, c'est prêt. Et on voit tout doucement des campagnes qui vont se développer, mais c'est de manière très isolée dans l'un ou l'autre pays.
Et c'est à partir de 2012, 2013, qui est notamment, mais y a aussi d'autres choses, le grand moment de la Manif pour tous, où on voit ces campagnes qui se développent un peu partout.
Et ce qui est intéressant, et ça, c'est un des éléments accélérateurs, c'est qu'on n'est plus du tout dans un combat catholique ou strictement catholique.
C'est-à-dire le pape continue à parler ce langage, d'autres acteurs importants aussi de l'Église catholique, mais d'autres religions se sont emparées de la question
et des acteurs non religieux se sont aussi emparés de la question.
Et c'est là où on voit, par exemple, des ponts avec le populisme. Et effectivement, et ça, on l'a vu dans les discussions sur le populisme,
le poids de la désinformation ou d'informations tronquées, le poids, par exemple, des réseaux sociaux.
On l'a vu avec Bolsonaro qui a été élu notamment grâce au discours anti-genre.
C'est aussi des réseaux sociaux, notamment le groupe WhatsApp, qui lui permettent de diffuser un certain nombre d'informations tronquées, malvenues, de créer des boucs émissaires,
ce qui est un mécanisme assez central dans les discours anti-genre.
Donc oui, ça a fonctionné assez bien ce discours.
Donc cette accélération qui a donc culminé, vous le disiez, au début des années 2010 avec la Manif pour tous en France.
Est-ce qu'il faut comprendre alors que
au début des années 2000, quand le mariage homosexuel a été légalisé en Belgique, est-ce que simplement cette idéologie-là n'était
pas encore assez mature, pas encore assez popularisée en Europe et c'est pour ça que finalement, chez nous, ça n'a pas fait grand bruit, y a pas eu de grandes manifestations à ce sujet alors qu'en France, c'était
le chaos dans les rues.
Est-ce que c'est lié à ça ?
Alors, le facteur, de nouveau, le facteur temps est important, mais je dirais pas de cette manière-là.
D'accord.
C'est-à-dire que ce qui s'est passé en Belgique ou dans les premiers pays qui se sont organisés, c'est que le discours inverse n'était pas prêt.
Donc en fait, ces mobilisations, ou plutôt ces opérations de résistance, si on veut, n'étaient pas encore prêtes quand ça a été adopté.
De manière générale, en Belgique, elles sont assez peu présentes par ailleurs. C'est un des rares pays européens où y a pas de campagne anti-genre, y a toujours pas de campagne anti-genre ou de manière très anecdotique.
C'est-à-dire y a quelques années-
Oui, l'Alliance Vita, par exemple.
Oui, mais qui est un acteur qui est tout à fait anecdotique dans le paysage et n'a pas réussi à avoir, euh-
Une place médiatique, par exemple
...ni une présence médiatique ni des acteurs politiques, hormis surtout le Vlaams Belang, mais au-delà du Vlaams Belang, y a très peu de liens au niveau politique pour des tas de raisons.
Donc c'est des mouvements qui restent assez anecdotiques. Après, y a un autre danger quand même qui pourrait venir de la question, c'est l'idée du backlash,
à laquelle personnellement, je pense que je rejette assez fort, notamment de penser que ces résistances ou ces réactions conservatrices auraient été provoquées par les discours progressistes ou par les demandes progressistes.
Et on peut objecter, on peut refuser cette idée pour plein de raisons.
On a des raisons théoriques, mais aussi des raisons empiriques. C'est-à-dire, on voit un certain nombre de pays où les réactions conservatrices viennent... la réaction vient avant l'action.
C'est-à-dire que la réponse conservatrice vient avant que les acteurs progressistes ne demandent quoi que ce soit. Donc en fait, en termes de temporalité, on voit pas une causalité très claire entre certaines demandes et certaines réactions.
On voit aussi, c'est le cas par exemple dans la comparaison entre l'Italie et la France, peu importe ce qu'on demande, on a la même réaction.
Donc les Français ont demandé le mariage entre personnes de même sexe. Les Italiens, on est loin d'être... encore aujourd'hui, on est loin de parler de mariage gay en Italie.
C'est un partenariat pas très généreux par ailleurs. Ben on a eu exactement la même campagne avec les mêmes affiches françaises traduites en italien.
Et donc là, y a autre chose. Et dans la littérature, y a deux grandes approches. C'est soit de considérer que ces mouvements conservateurs sont une réponse, si on veut un peu du berger à la bergère, ou c'est une réponse,
une reconquête, par exemple, ce que certains vont appeler de l'hétéroactivisme ou c'est l'empire qui frappe, qui revient.
Ça, c'est vraiment l'idée de backlash. D'autres personnes vont dire : « En fait, y a autre chose qui se joue, c'est plus complexe.
Il y a ces éléments de résistance par rapport à l'ordre du genre et de la sexualité, mais y a aussi le rôle de symbole que jouent le genre et la sexualité pour pouvoir articuler d'autres combats.
» Et par exemple, c'est quelque chose qu'on peut essayer de comprendre à la lumière de ce qui se passe en Russie ou en Hongrie.
Probablement que des gens comme Vladimir Poutine ou Viktor Orbán, à titre personnel,
ne sont pas des gens très progressistes sur les questions de genre et de sexualité, mais ne sont pas non plus obsédés par ces questions, comme par exemple le cardinal Ratzinger, donc pape Benoît XVI,
pouvait tout à fait être obsédé et travailler depuis très longtemps par ces questions.
Par contre, des gens comme Poutine ou comme Orbán ont compris l'intérêt symbolique qu'ils pouvaient tirer de ces questions-là pour mobiliser, pour faire des ponts avec d'autres discours, pour relancer certains arguments.
Et par exemple, pour donner un exemple quand on parlait de conspiration, un argument qu'on voit de plus en plus dans les discours anti-genre, c'est l'argument du grand remplacement, qui historiquement n'est pas un élément des discours anti-genre.
Et dans les discours catholiques, on ne trouve pas le grand remplacement.
Ce qu'on voit, c'est l'hiver démographique, c'est-à-dire l'idée que avec la contraception, avec l'avancée des droits des femmes, des personnes LGBT, y a de moins en moins d'enfants.
Et donc y a un problème démographique qui surgit, d'où l'idée d'hiver. Par contre, y a pas de lien avec une islamisation de l'Europe ou ce genre de choses.
Et là, on a des acteurs d'extrême droite qui avaient le discours du grand remplacement, qui ont vu un intérêt à utiliser les campagnes anti-genre, en gros, pour relancer leur discours sur le grand remplacement,
en disant : « Ben, si y a une islamisation de l'Europe, conséquence du grand remplacement, c'est parce que les femmes ne font plus d'enfants.
» Et donc y a là un espace vide qui est laissé et dans lequel d'autres personnes peuvent s'engouffrer. Et par exemple, c'est une combinaison que Viktor Orbán fait très bien.
Et y a des discours où il explique clairement que si on ne lutte pas contre l'idéologie du genre, ben y aura plus de Hongrois dans quelques années.
Oui. Alors juste pour revenir sur un élément, pour revenir juste un instant sur notre petite Belgique, vous expliquez qu'on était une exception, qu'on était un des rares territoires où,
voilà, les acteurs type Alliance Vita, les acteurs qui ont ces positions anti-genre
ne sont pas très présents du tout.
Comment est-ce qu'on explique cette exception ?
Alors, y a beaucoup de facteurs. Y a le facteur temporalité dont on parlait. C'est-à-dire que quand les réformes ont été adoptées, en fait, la réaction n'était pas prête.
La recette conservatrice, qui est à peu près la même dans plein de pays, c'est-à-dire que quand on étudie
en Europe, mais même en Amérique latine, on voit à peu près les mêmes campagnes, les mêmes arguments, les mêmes slogans, mais ça, c'était pas prêt, simplement.
Donc la Belgique a adopté ça avant. Ceci dit, on voit que ça, c'est vrai aussi des Pays-Bas, mais les Pays-Bas, on voit des campagnes conservatrices qui se développent.
Et là, je pense qu'y a plusieurs facteurs. Donc sur le plan religieux, d'une part, l'Église catholique belge, y a eu l'épisode de Monseigneur Léonard, mais qui a été un échec.
Monseigneur Léonard n'était même pas suivi par les catholiques eux-mêmes.
Et donc y a un peu un retour à la ligne beaucoup plus modérée de l'Église catholique de Belgique,
qui ne voit pas un grand intérêt à se mobiliser sur ces questions-là, ce qui est à l'inverse d'autres pays où elle a pu mettre tout... le cas de la France est emblématique.
La Manif pour tous n'aurait jamais fonctionné de la même manière si l'Église n'avait pas prêté des salles paroissiales, n'avait pas prêté des ressources, ses réseaux de communication, etc.
Et on a aussi, de manière générale, un catholicisme au niveau des communautés catholiques beaucoup moins conservateur en Belgique qu'il ne l'est en France.
Et comment est-ce qu'on explique ça ?
Y a beaucoup d'explications. Maintenant, certains de mes collègues pourraient aussi s'interroger sur le poids de la laïcité à la française,
qui a aussi radicalisés, d'une certaine manière, les catholiques français, alors qu'en Belgique, les catholiques ont beaucoup de pouvoir, beaucoup de présence dans la société.
Et, mais de manière beaucoup plus modérée. C'est-à-dire la plupart des enfants belges vont dans des écoles catholiques, la plupart des universités belges sont catholiques,
même si elles ne sont plus sous l'autorité directe ni du cardinal ni du pape.
Et après, l'autre facteur, c'est vrai, c'est l'extrême droite belge n'a pas eu un grand intérêt à s'emparer de la question.
Parce que, ben du côté francophone, y a pas une grande extrême droite, elle reste un acteur marginal,
Le Parti populaire n'existe plus, par exemple.
Voilà, c'est ça. Donc on n'a pas un acteur très important qui aurait pu s'emparer de ça et construire quelque chose à partir de ça, ce qui a été fait dans beaucoup de pays.
Et du côté flamand, donc effectivement, les plus grands alliés sont du côté du Vlaams Belang, parfois la N-VA.
Mais y a eu des tentatives, par exemple, de Theo Francken, qui a fait quelques tweets sur les hommes qui s'habillent en femmes et des choses comme ça.
Ça a provoqué un tel tollé en Flandre qu'en fait, il a arrêté assez rapidement ce discours.
Oui, Bart De Wever était revenu en disant : « Ce ne sont pas les positions du parti, c'est juste sa position à lui. Il a le droit de dire ce qu'il veut, mais c'est pas la N-VA qui dit ça. »
Probablement, Theo Francken a fait un ballon d'essai, mais qui n'a pas vraiment marché. Et donc les principaux soutiens sont au niveau du Vlaams Belang, surtout des gens comme Dries Van Langenhove, par exemple,
qui est clairement sur cette ligne-là,
mais le Vlaams Belang a d'autres enjeux, surtout autour de l'immigration, qui prennent plus de place.
Donc pour l'instant, y a aucun acteur qui a eu un intérêt à se saisir de cette question-là. Ceci dit, ça peut arriver.
C'est-à-dire, on voit vraiment dans plein de pays, y compris aujourd'hui en Grande-Bretagne, aux Pays-Bas, en Scandinavie, on voit ces luttes se développer, ce qui était pas le cas y a cinq ans.
Donc ça arrivera peut-être un jour en Belgique.
Donc voilà, on approche,
par détour de la question de l'importance de l'acteur qu'est l'Église. Donc, et donc si je comprends bien, la différence, pour caricaturer un peu, entre
l'Église catholique en Belgique et en France, c'est qu'en Belgique, elle a encore historiquement une
présence importante dans le débat public, dans les acteurs politiques, le fameux pilier catholique, les écoles, les hôpitaux, les partis politiques,
voilà, même encore aujourd'hui, on a au gouvernement un parti ouvertement chrétien.
Alors qu'en France, au contraire, on n'est pas présent officiellement, voilà, au sein du gouvernement, au sein des institutions politiques.
Et donc peut-être un discours beaucoup plus, ben proche de ce que va dire un discours plus radical, proche de ce que va dire justement le Vatican.
Et voilà. Est-ce que c'est ça la différence ?
Et ben disons que les Églises se sont construites différemment. Y a aussi la question de la pilarisation qui est centrale dans le contexte belge, donc cette division de la société en piliers idéologiques, notamment.
Et donc là, le pilier laïque versus le pilier catholique. Donc dans le cadre français, y a eu cette séparation très forte entre les deux, avec une autonomisation de l'Église.
Dans le contexte belge, l'Église est un acteur politique et social important et dans le contexte de la pilarisation, donc ces mondes segmentés, notamment sur une base philosophique avec le pilier laïque ou le pilier catholique,
y a une vraie présence de l'Église dans la société.
Et par ailleurs, on a dans le même cadre en Belgique aussi une présence très forte de la démocratie chrétienne qui est faible en France historiquement.
Et donc cette idée que ce monde catholique est aussi à l'écoute de la société et a beaucoup changé sur beaucoup de choses dans le contexte belge,
ce qui était moins vrai en France où c'était un acteur qui était beaucoup plus radicalisé et beaucoup plus aussi mis sur le, sur la sellette d'une certaine manière.
Donc en Belgique, des questions sur le genre et la sexualité se sont posées dans le monde catholique très tôt, au-delà de l'Église, c'est-à-dire dans toutes les associations du monde catholique, les universités, les écoles.
Par exemple, les débats sur la contraception, ça fait depuis les années 50, 60 qu'y a une réflexion sur : est-ce que les catholiques doivent avoir accès ou pas à la contraception ?
On se rappellera de figures comme le chaman de Loches par exemple. Mais toutes ces évolutions ont fait que le monde catholique belge a évolué autrement sur d'autres positions qui sont pas des positions
très conservatrices, ultra-conservatrices, qui étaient celles qui ont été développées au Vatican.
Mais donc voilà, je le disais, on tourne un petit peu autour de cet acteur central qu'est le Vatican. Historiquement, quand est-ce que le Vatican a commencé à développer ce discours-là anti-genre ?
Ben y a une histoire ancienne, qui remonte certainement au pape Paul VI, mais même de manière plus ancienne.
Donc l'Église n'a pas toujours été obsédée par les questions de genre et de sexualité,
mais à partir du moment où les sociétés changent et tous les débats, par exemple, sur Humanæ vitæ avec Paul VI, donc sur la question de la contraception,
toute la question de savoir si l'Église peut reconnaître la contraception pour les catholiques.
Donc je parlais dans le contexte belge, quelqu'un comme le cardinal Suenens va beaucoup travailler ces questions et va être un de ceux qui va aller contre la position officielle du Vatican.
À ce moment-là, ce qu'on voit dans le contexte du Vatican, c'est un raidissement sur toutes ces questions sociétales, sur tous ces changements qui traversent les sociétés occidentales, avant et puis dans le reste du monde.
Et dans ce contexte-là, un accrochage, si vous voulez, à la transformation, le genre et la sexualité deviennent ce qui incarnerait ce qu'être catholique dans les dernières décennies du travail de l'Église.
Et ce travail va s'intensifier avec Jean-Paul II et puis avec Benoît XVI, d'abord comme cardinal Ratzinger, et donc un des personnages les plus puissants sous le pontificat de Jean-Paul II et après sous son propre pontificat,
avec la production d'énormément de textes conservateurs sur les questions de genre et de sexualité.
Y a toutes les polémiques sur le préservatif, par exemple, avec Jean-Paul II, qui sont très connues. Y en a d'autres. Donc y a tout ce contexte d'un raidissement catholique sur ces questions.
À côté de ça, le discours anti-genre va venir s'installer là-dedans. Et ça, c'est vraiment comme j'avais expliqué, c'est vraiment une réponse aux avancées aux Nations unies dans les années 90.
À l'époque, le pape Jean-Paul II a essayé de mobiliser tous les ressorts qu'il avait au niveau des Nations unies. Faut pas oublier que le Vatican, sous le Saint-Siège, est un membre de
l'Organisation des Nations unies,
un observateur, mais ils sont quand même présents dans les lieux de discussion.
Et par ailleurs, de s'appuyer sur un réseau d'États catholiques qui ont appuyé des positions catholiques et également travailler avec un réseau d'États musulmans.
Et ils ont réussi à bloquer des choses dans ces conférences des Nations unies, mais pas tout. Et donc, à partir de là, y a la volonté de développer un autre discours.
Et le discours anti-genre qui est la réponse à ça va permettre de redonner vie à tout ce discours conservateur plus général qui était celui de l'Église catholique.
Ouais. Donc j'entends qu'ils n'ont pas toujours été obsédés par ces questions-là et puis un développement sous certaines personnes.
Vous citez notamment régulièrement le pape Benoît XVI.
C'est peut-être une bête question, mais quel est le motif, quelle est la poussée initiale qui amène le Vatican à se radicaliser sur cette question-là précisément ?
Y a des facteurs personnels et des facteurs théologiques, donc des facteurs de certains acteurs pour lesquels ce sont des questions importantes.
À l'inverse, par exemple, le pape Benoît XVI n'a pas fait de grandes ouvertures doctrinales sur ces questions. C'est-à-dire, il a un discours plus accueillant,
mais il a pas changé la doctrine de l'Église catholique, ni sur le genre, ni sur l'avortement, ni sur l'homosexualité.
Mais ce ne sont pas des questions qui l'intéressent beaucoup. C'est-à-dire, les intérêts du pape sont sur la pauvreté, l'environnement, voilà, d'autres enjeux.
Les autres papes étaient vraiment intéressés par ça.
Après, y a aussi des éléments plus fondamentaux, et notamment des éléments théologiques sur la libre disposition des individus, sur la possibilité de faire ce qu'on veut avec son corps,
sur l'usage qu'on peut avoir de sa sexualité.
Encore aujourd'hui, dans la doctrine catholique, la sexualité est uniquement acceptée à des fins de reproduction.
Ce qui veut dire aussi d'ailleurs que les rapports hétérosexuels qui ne visent pas la reproduction en théorie n'entrent pas dans ce qui est accepté par l'Église.
Donc y a là un certain nombre d'éléments où les évolutions de la société viennent contre des points de doctrine de l'Église.
Et cette doctrine évolue très lentement. Pour l'instant, y a quelques petites avancées, mais on est très loin d'évolutions.
Et donc on a un décalage, mais qui date déjà de plusieurs dizaines d'années, un décalage qui s'est creusé entre le discours de l'Église qui a peu changé et le discours de la société qui a énormément changé.
Ça répond tout à fait à ma question. Attends, vous avez parlé de sensibilité personnelle, voilà, de certains acteurs.
Je sais pas si vous aviez lu le livre de Frédéric Martel à l'époque, il y a quelques années, donc ça s'appelait Sodoma.
Donc y a donc-- qui, voilà, qui accusait simplement le, le, le, enfin qui présentait le,
l'idée, le fait qu'y avait de nombreuses personnalités au sein du Vatican qui sont elles-mêmes, voilà, des prêtres qui sont eux-mêmes homosexuels.
Et comme quoi y avait un grand agacement vis-à-vis de ça et donc d'une réponse très ferme vis-à-vis de ces questions-là.
Est-ce que ça, c'est également un aspect qui a pu jouer dans les positions de certaines personnalités au sein du Vatican ?
Ça a probablement joué, mais je dirais pas... enfin, le livre de Martel est très anecdotique. Donc il raconte un certain nombre d'histoires sur des personnalités-
Des rencontres, des prostituées qu'il a interviewées, et cetera, voilà.
Voilà. Donc y a effectivement ça. Donc y a très clairement une relation ancienne, très forte entre le catholicisme et l'homosexualité masculine surtout, homosexualité féminine aussi dans un certain nombre d'ordres,
mais qui ont beaucoup moins de pouvoir.
Donc ça, c'est clair que c'est présent. Par ailleurs, l'Église est constituée et a longtemps constitué une des communautés masculines par définition.
L'armée était une autre. Ça veut dire aussi que c'est un espace où on peut, si on veut être entouré d'hommes, c'est un espace que l'on peut... où on peut essayer d'accéder,
où y a pas le besoin de se marier avec une femme puisque c'est interdit aux prêtres.
Donc ça permet de résoudre certaines questions à des époques où elles étaient plus compliquées à résoudre. Donc y a quand même ce passé-là qui est très présent,
avec une dimension très homoérotique depuis le début de l'histoire de l'Église.
Donc ça, c'est quelque chose qui traverse toute l'histoire du catholicisme. Donc ça, c'est présent.
On pense aux images de, je crois que c'était Benoît XVI, où y a ces photos qui circulent régulièrement de lui face à des danseurs torse nu qui font une danse assez torride.
C'est des photos que j'aime beaucoup.
Oui, ou le nombre d'histoires de papes homosexuels, je pense à Jules II, par exemple, et donc voilà, qui a demandé à
Michel-Ange, homosexuel lui-même, de faire un certain nombre de représentations qui montrent clairement des formes d'homoérotisme.
Et on a ça beaucoup. Y a qu'à imaginer les statues de Saint Sébastien, par exemple, très nombreuses, très langoureuses. Donc y a cette histoire ancienne qui est présente.
Après, y a aussi dans ce raidissement contemporain, ce que montrent des travaux de collègues comme par exemple Jocelyn Tricou de l'Université de Lausanne, qui a travaillé sur la masculinité des prêtres,
qui est un peu une énigme, la masculinité des prêtres, parce qu'y a rien... 'fin, c'est des hommes qui portent des robes par définition, donc y a rien de moins masculin que de porter une robe.
Et c'est un personnage qui est hors de l'ordre du genre, le prêtre, qui est dans un autre type de masculinité.
C'est une question qui s'est longtemps posée, c'est qui est le plus masculin, le plus viril entre le prêtre qui échappe au désir sexuel soi-disant et voilà, le soldat violent qui fait couler le sang, et cetera.
Et donc on a ces personnages-là. Et donc dans le travail de Jocelyn, ce qu'il montre,
c'est notamment que dans le contexte français, les prêtres homosexuels sont en général les plus conservateurs, avec
un impensé de leur sexualité.
C'est-à-dire, y a un certain nombre d'actes qu'ils peuvent pratiquer ou pas, mais qu'ils dissocient complètement de leur fonction de prêtre.
Et donc y a pas de réflexion et c'était confirmé par d'autres personnes comme Krzysztof Charamsa, ce prêtre polonais qui était dans des très hautes fonctions au Vatican et qui a quitté les ordres en annonçant qu'il était avec un autre homme
et a aussi levé le voile sur la question de l'homosexualité dans l'Église.
Ce qu'il disait, moi, j'ai eu l'occasion de le rencontrer à deux ou trois reprises, c'était notamment que y a aucune réflexion sur la sexualité et encore moins sur l'homosexualité.
Donc y a un impensé.
Y a un impensé qui, au lieu de...
d'essayer de comprendre ce qui se passe, d'accompagner, c'est la même chose sur le genre, ben c'est de le mettre à l'écart, de le refuser,
même si par ailleurs, ses propres comportements peuvent être en décalage par rapport à la parole qu'on porte.
Mhm mhm. Alors donc revenons à l'action politique même du Vatican. Donc on comprend, voilà, que ce discours s'est développé pour toute une série de raisons que vous avez présentées.
Comment est-ce que, à partir de ce discours, le Vatican opère, disons, à l'international pour solidifier, pour concrétiser donc ces idées-là, entre guillemets, dans la rue ?
Ben ça s'est fait petit à petit. Donc c'est vraiment un processus lent et c'est ce qu'on voit dans la temporalité.
Donc le discours est prêt un peu avant 2005. 2003, 2004, on a plusieurs documents importants qui sont publiés, notamment un livre assez amusant qui s'appelle Le lexique des termes ambigus et controversés, qui est un dictionnaire
de termes que le Vatican n'aime pas.
Et donc ce sont des articles qui définissent, ce sont souvent des republications, un certain nombre de choses comme homosexualité, avortement, euthanasie, que sais-je, ce genre de questions éthiques.
Et donc tout ça est consolidé, est prêt et cristallisé à ce moment-là. Et après, c'est une lente diffusion avant de voir la mobilisation dans les rues.
Donc c'est comment est-ce qu'on va arriver à diffuser ce discours.
Et alors là, l'Église va s'appuyer avant tout sur ses propres relais,
donc relais dans des universités catholiques où on voit des journées d'études qui se développent sur ces questions, dans des salles paroissiales, dans des maisons d'édition, dans des réseaux de médias, des radios, des choses comme ça,
qui, de nouveau, suivant les pays, vont avoir une ligne idéologique ou une autre.
En Belgique, ils sont pas très conservateurs pour la plupart d'entre eux. Dans d'autres pays, je sais pas, la Pologne, l'Italie le sont beaucoup plus.
Et donc ont pu faire des--
ont pu diffuser cette pensée.
Et plusieurs collègues, par exemple sur le cas italien, ont montré comment on a une multiplication pendant des années de conférences dans des salles paroissiales où on a des militants qui, religieux ou non,
mais beaucoup sont des laïcs, qui vont aller répéter un peu partout en Italie, dans des salles paroissiales, ce discours sur le genre.
Et c'est comme ça que progressivement, ça va faire sens pour un certain nombre d'acteurs dans le monde catholique, avant que des acteurs non catholiques s'en emparent.
Et là notamment, c'est la droite populiste ou l'extrême droite qui vont s'en emparer, parfois avec des relations compliquées avec le Vatican.
De nouveau, le cas italien est intéressant parce qu'on a eu et on a toujours un conflit fort entre le Vatican sous le pape François et la Ligue du Nord, enfin la Ligue maintenant, avec Matteo Salvini.
Et les deux vont se saisir du discours anti-genre. C'est-à-dire le pape François continue à utiliser le discours anti-genre que sa propre institution a inventé
et des acteurs comme Matteo Salvini s'en sont emparés, notamment comme je disais avant, pour promouvoir le grand remplacement ou d'autres types de théories, d'autres théories de ce type.
Et donc dans ce contexte-là, en même temps, ils vont s'affronter entre eux et y a une certaine dépossession de la part de,
d'un certain nombre d'acteurs catholiques, de discours qu'ils ont eux-mêmes inventés et qui sont repris par d'autres et qui maintenant vivent leur vie.
C'est-à-dire y a plus un contrôle catholique aujourd'hui sur ces campagnes. Une formule que j'ai utilisée dans plusieurs textes, c'est Frankenstein.
Donc si on prend l'histoire de Frankenstein, bon, Frankenstein, c'est pas le monstre, c'est celui qui a inventé le monstre et il n'arrive pas à le retrouver.
C'est-à-dire le monstre va finir par vivre sa vie et il échappe au contrôle de celui qui l'a inventé. On a ça avec les discours sur le genre.
C'est à la fois un des plus grands succès catholiques récents, c'est-à-dire que c'est une catégorie qui est devenue aujourd'hui très très importante.
On a des politiques internationales anti-genre promues par des acteurs aussi importants que le Brésil, la Russie ou les États-Unis sous Donald Trump.
Donc ça, c'est vraiment un succès,
mais en même temps, ça échappe à l'Église aujourd'hui. C'est-à-dire le Brésil ou les États-Unis ou encore plus la Russie n'ont pas demandé au pape l'autorisation d'utiliser ces catégories pour des politiques internationales.
Et ça, c'est un peu le paradoxe de la situation actuelle.
Ouais. C'était justement la question que j'allais poser, mais vous l'avez magnifiquement anticipée.
Mais je vais revenir alors sur la notion de backlash donc que vous avez remise en question tout à l'heure.
Donc, vous n'adhérez pas à cette définition, donc définie par,
Susan Faludi, donc dans les années 90, cette idée que y a ce,
cette réaction automatique, mécanique de, voilà, on fait une avancée au niveau des droits des femmes, au niveau des droits des minorités sexuelles,
automatiquement, mécaniquement, va y avoir une oppression, une violence, une agression envers ces communautés-là.
Vous n'adhérez pas à cette définition ?
Eh ben, je dirais
d'une part, y a dans l'ouvrage de Faludi, y a peu de définitions d'abord. Donc
elle ne définit pas vraiment, elle explique plus ou moins ce que c'est, mais c'est vrai qu'après, quand on essaye de creuser, de trouver une définition,
y a cette idée d'automaticité.
Alors déjà, en général, les historiens nous ont appris qu'une telle automaticité n'existe pas dans les processus sociaux.
Y a rien qui est automatique, c'est pas une réaction chimique, c'est, voilà. Il faut un certain nombre d'acteurs qui s'emparent d'un certain nombre de questions.
Et ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui avec les débats autour des campagnes anti-genre, c'est qu'on a des acteurs extrêmement différents qui s'emparent des mêmes questions, mais qui n'ont pas nécessairement les mêmes projets.
C'est-à-dire les projets du Vatican ne sont pas ceux de Vladimir Poutine nécessairement ou ceux de l'extrême droite.
Donc y a déjà cette complexité d'acteurs qui est importante.
Y a aussi, bon, y a un certain nombre d'objections, mais parmi les autres objections, y a des objections empiriques dont j'ai déjà parlé,
c'est-à-dire sur cette idée que en fait la réaction parfois précède l'action, c'est-à-dire qu'y a pas une séquence très claire.
Y a pas non plus une séquence claire où telle demande va provoquer telle réaction. Par exemple, certaines féministes ont dit : « Non, mais tout cela, c'est à cause des revendications LGBT ou des revendications trans,
ou des trucs gays », des choses comme ça.
Ça a été entendu. Bah en fait, c'est pas vrai, ça dépend des pays. Exemple récent, si on prend la Bulgarie et la Roumanie, c'est des pays qui entrent tardivement dans les campagnes anti-genre, 2016, 2017, 2018.
Eh bien, en Bulgarie, c'est sur la Convention d'Istanbul, c'est-à-dire le document du Conseil de l'Europe qui permet de lutter contre les violences de genre.
En Roumanie, c'est sur la question de la définition constitutionnelle du mariage. Donc deux questions totalement différentes provoquent exactement la même campagne avec les mêmes arguments, les mêmes acteurs.
Ce qui nous fait dire d'une part qu'en fait, y a un discours qui est déjà prêt.
Y a un kit. Et donc avec plusieurs collègues, on a rebaptisé ces campagnes anti-genre en fait comme un kit transnational, dont une des forces, c'est qu'il est très plastique, il est très adaptable.
Donc on a aujourd'hui un-- voilà, comme y a d'autres kits, ben c'est un truc dont les acteurs peuvent se servir. Y a des arguments, y a des campagnes, y a des modes d'action, etc.
Et c'est quelque chose dont des acteurs conservateurs peuvent se saisir pour avancer dans plusieurs pays contre différentes choses.
C'est-à-dire c'est pas nécessairement lié à ce qui se passe dans un pays parce que la même chose se passe dans un autre pays avec d'autres revendications.
Et donc si on est juste dans une réaction mécanique, si on voit juste l'idée que ces hommes conservateurs ou ces femmes conservatrices ou ces acteurs religieux veulent empêcher l'avancée des droits,
dimension qui est présente,
on perd toute cette complexité, on perd aussi cette dimension stratégique, cette dimension d'instrumentalisation de ces campagnes.
Et après, y a aussi un risque politique très grand. Enfin y a plusieurs risques politiques. D'abord, ce qu'on voit avec les campagnes anti-genre,
c'est qu'elles arrivent à mettre dans le même paquet des tas de choses a priori assez différentes, sauf que pour l'Église, elles font partie de la même chose.
C'est-à-dire, par exemple, les féministes et les militants, militantes LGBT.
Exemple très concret, si on prend les mères porteuses, donc la question de la gestation pour autrui, eh bien c'est un bon exemple où on a des oppositions fortes entre certains militants gays et certaines militantes féministes.
Donc ça va pas nécessairement ensemble. Y a pas une grande conspiration, mais le discours anti-genre met tout ça dans le même paquet.
Difficulté pour les acteurs qui sont attaqués par les discours anti-genre, c'est d'arriver à s'entendre alors qu'en fait, ils sont en train de se disputer sur un certain nombre de questions.
Et donc parfois, on est obsédé par les petits silos, par ces petits sujets qu'on étudie sans voir qu'en fait on a quelque chose de beaucoup plus large.
Ce qui amène aussi à voir des liens entre les discours anti-genre et d'autres attaques et les attaques contre les études de genre par exemple le montrent.
Mais en Hongrie, Viktor Orbán n'attaque pas que les études de genre, il attaque les études sur la migration, il attaque les études sur la démocratie, il a forcé une université à quitter le pays.
Donc c'est des attaques plus générales sur la liberté académique, la liberté de pensée. Et c'est là où on se dit y a autre chose qui porte sur les attaques contre la démocratie telle qu'on la connaît aujourd'hui.
Ou en fait c'est juste un versant de quelque chose de plus large qui fait partie de l'ordre du genre. L'ordre du genre et sexualité est un des éléments, mais c'est plus large que ça.
Et le dernier élément aussi, c'est avec le backlash,
c'est le risque de s'autocensurer. C'est-à-dire si on pense que les réactions conservatrices sont provoquées par les demandes progressistes, puis alors la réaction logique, c'est que les progressistes devraient se modérer
pour ne pas avoir ces réactions de backlash.
La seule chose, c'est qu'empiriquement, ce raisonnement ne marche pas parce que même quand on se modère ou même quand on demande pas quelque chose, y a déjà dans un certain nombre de pays cette réaction conservatrice.
Ouais, ouais, ouais. Alors on va s'attaquer à la question de la crise de la démocratie, que vous abordiez y a un instant.
Juste une autre question, c'est que dans les exemples que vous donniez, donc la Pologne, les États-Unis, la France et voilà, on a surtout des exemples de
pays occidentaux, éventuellement des pays avec un passé colonial comme le Brésil.
Est-ce qu'on trouve ces discours, ces campagnes anti-genre par exemple en Asie, par exemple en Afrique, par exemple dans les pays en voie de développement ?
Alors les deux grands pôles historiques
des campagnes anti-genre et ça, c'était lié au catholicisme historiquement, c'est l'Europe et avant tout l'Europe catholique, même si aujourd'hui ça s'est répandu dans l'Europe orthodoxe et dans l'Europe protestante et l'Amérique latine.
C'est les deux grands pôles historiques. Ça s'est développé aux États-Unis et ce discours est de plus en plus présent aux États-Unis.
Il n'était pas tellement y a quelques années et on le voit aussi se développer en Afrique, mais on manque de données. Mais il est présent.
Y a des collègues qui sont en train de travailler là-dessus aujourd'hui.
En Ouganda par exemple.
Ben y a deux choses. Y a le cas par exemple, l'Ouganda est un bon exemple. Y a eu une exportation de campagnes homophobes par exemple de pasteurs protestants
qui n'étaient pas vraiment dans le même type de campagne que les campagnes anti-genre, même s'y a beaucoup de convergences.
Mais on voit aussi aujourd'hui le développement de campagnes proprement anti-genre, notamment parce que les acteurs des États-Unis les ont empruntées, les ont adoptées et aussi parce qu'y a d'autres acteurs qui sont présents.
Mais là, on manque encore de données, mais en Afrique, c'est clairement présent. En Asie, c'est beaucoup plus compliqué.
Y a par exemple des utilisations, on trouve ce type d'argument chez Erdogan en Turquie, c'est présent. On le trouve aussi dans des pays qui sont historiquement catholiques comme les Philippines par exemple.
Donc là, c'est clairement présent aussi. Et après on a des cas plus étonnants, et qui de nouveau ont besoin de plus de recherches parce qu'on a peu d'informations comme par exemple Taïwan.
Donc Taïwan a été le premier pays en Asie à légaliser le mariage entre personnes de même sexe.
Et y a eu une résistance, m'a-t-on expliqué, plusieurs collègues m'ont expliqué, qui venait d'acteurs de la droite chrétienne taïwanaise.
C'est-à-dire que dans beaucoup de pays,
la droite chrétienne des États-Unis a investi,
d'ailleurs en Europe, elle a ouvert plein de bureaux en Europe, on en a à Bruxelles plusieurs, qui donc ont investi des bureaux y compris en Asie et ont développé un certain nombre de discours.
Et donc on a eu des développements de poches de groupes chrétiens protestants très conservateurs, mais qui ont un certain pouvoir d'influence dans plusieurs pays asiatiques, dont Taïwan.
Et après donc ça, c'est sur les campagnes anti-genre au sens strict et au sens large, on a des discours conservateurs dans le domaine du genre, notamment du genre et de la sexualité associés avec un nationalisme exacerbé,
mais qui sont pas les campagnes anti-genre, qui sont un autre phénomène, par exemple en Inde aujourd'hui avec Modi.
Donc y a des articulations possibles avec d'autres discours.
En Chine aujourd'hui aussi, on a-- le discours anti-genre est pas vraiment présent,
mais on a un raidissement sur des questions de sexualité par exemple aussi et qui s'inscrivent dans une perte de démocratie et qui s'inscrivent également dans une remise en cause de la démocratie libérale,
dans une remise en cause de la liberté d'expression, etc.,
dans un contexte nationaliste.
Donc on voit des articulations similaires, mais différentes, d'un phénomène différent dans plusieurs pays en Asie.
Oui. L'exemple qui me vient en Chine, c'est notamment, je crois récemment une législation pour
interdire l'espèce de stars type J-pop, type voilà garçon avec une masculinité assez douce qui était interdit pour des raisons assez floues, pas très clairement expliquées. Donc c'est, ça-
Oui. Et là, on a un autre lien qui est intéressant sur les questions du masculinisme qui est le lien très ancien étudié par exemple dans les années 30 sur les propagandes fascistes entre masculinité exacerbée-
Mmh mmh
...on pourrait dire masculinisme, une idéologie masculine et des formes de nationalisme prononcé, de nationalité fascisant, totalitaire, etc.
Quelque chose qu'on a vu dans les régimes fascistes, les régimes nazis, etc., où y avait l'exaltation d'une certaine masculinité très musclée.
Dans le communisme stalinien aussi, on a ces ouvriers très très forts, très musclés. Donc on a ces images-là et on les retrouve aujourd'hui dans des régimes où le nationalisme est de plus en plus marqué,
comme par exemple aujourd'hui en Chine ou en Inde.
Et ce qui est intéressant dans ces articulations au niveau global, ben la Russie, d'une part a utilisé les expressions comme, 'fin autour du genre et des campagnes anti-genre.
Donc elle a utilisé ce discours-là. Elle a aussi inventé autre chose qui sont les valeurs traditionnelles qui recouvrent en partie les campagnes anti-genre.
Ce qui est fascinant avec les valeurs traditionnelles, c'est que ça permet des alliances beaucoup plus larges.
Parce que bon, jamais personne ne sait ce que sont les valeurs traditionnelles et les anthropologues diront très bien que les traditions sont des choses assez récentes, mais en même temps tout le monde a des valeurs traditionnelles.
Donc on peut articuler, même si les traditions sont pas les mêmes, on peut articuler un consensus autour d'une défense de ces soi-disant valeurs traditionnelles.
Ça permet une certaine universalité de la cause.
Exactement. Et ça, c'est une invention russe qui est assez fantastique pour ça.
Ouais. Alors donc vous expliquez qu'il y avait un-- vous placiez ces campagnes, ces mouvements anti-genre, au sein d'un mouvement plus large qui serait la crise de la démocratie.
Est-ce que vous pouvez approfondir cette question-là ?
Eh ben disons, y a d'une part ce qui relève vraiment de la démocratie sexuelle ou de genre et démocratie, c'est-à-dire toutes les réflexions qui ont montré que
l'approfondissement, l'élargissement des droits des femmes, des minorités sexuelles, c'est un élément central de la démocratie.
Donc y a d'abord une attaque directe contre ça,
en refusant des droits, en essayant de les limiter, en revenant par exemple sur le droit à l'avortement dans plein de pays ou en essayant de le faire comme en Pologne, en Espagne, en Italie.
Donc y a ça, premièrement.
Et après, l'autre élément, c'est combien d'acteurs, et là, c'est beaucoup plus les acteurs politiques qui ont pris les campagnes anti-genre ou les acteurs associatifs,
sont des acteurs qui ont un agenda plus large de remise en cause de la démocratie,
de limiter les droits.
Et on le voit par exemple avec des acteurs comme Viktor Orbán, comme Vladimir Poutine ou des acteurs de ce type qui ont compris l'intérêt qu'ils pouvaient tirer des campagnes anti-genre.
C'est-à-dire c'est inversant de ce qu'ils font et ça permet de limiter des droits. Ça permet à leurs acteurs qui sont des acteurs anti-genre en leur sein d'être contents.
Ça permet de parler à certains publics,
mais en plus, c'est un symbole très fort qu'on peut agiter pour viser plus largement, pour créer des boucs émissaires par exemple, ou pour attaquer plus largement un certain nombre de questions, d'enjeux.
Et je parlais de la liberté académique en Hongrie, ben ça, on le voit très bien. Donc Viktor Orbán, depuis plusieurs années, a profondément transformé les universités, le paysage de l'enseignement supérieur en Hongrie. En ré-
Il a fait en sorte que les études, les études de genre ne soient plus subsidiées, ouais.
Voilà, donc il a fait ça, mais il a fait plein d'autres choses. Donc le cas le plus emblématique, c'est il a forcé une université à quitter, c'est
un cas unique en Europe, donc la Central European University, qui a été fondée et financée par l'Open Society de George Soros-
Mmh
...a dû, qui était une excellente université basée à Budapest, a dû, après des années de négociations avec le pouvoir hongrois, quitter la Hongrie et aller s'installer à Vienne.
Donc ça, c'est le cas le plus emblématique. Y a plein d'autres exemples, c'est-à-dire l'autonomie des universités a été perdue.
Orbán a placé des proches à la tête de plein d'institutions universitaires, une intervention directe dans la gouvernance des universités, dans le financement, dans, voilà, l'équivalent du FNRS en Hongrie a été profondément réformé
pour être plus conforme à ce que le pouvoir demande et pour ne pas produire des discours contraires.
Et dans ce contexte-là,
en fait, les études de genre, comme les études sur les questions migratoires, et on se rappellera ce qu'Orbán disait au moment de l'arrivée de réfugiés syriens en Europe,
à ce moment-là que ça se joue, ben ce sont deux symboles qu'Orbán utilise pour attaquer plus largement autre chose.
C'est des symboles qui sont clairs, qui sont visibles, que les gens comprennent. Si vous parlez d'autonomie des universités, pour les personnes c'est très vague et c'est très abstrait.
Si on parle d'études de genre ou d'études sur les migrations, c'est très clair. Et donc ça permet de faire passer un discours, ça permet d'articuler des questions.
Et c'est quelque chose que le genre a fait depuis toujours. C'est-à-dire le genre, c'est à la fois un rapport de pouvoir en tant que tel,
mais c'est aussi, dirait Joan Scott, dirait la théoricienne et historienne états-unienne Joan Scott, c'est aussi une manière d'articuler des rapports de pouvoir, de les exprimer, de les formuler.
Et donc on va parfois parler dans le discours du genre, on va exprimer d'autres rapports de pouvoir. Exemple très clair, ben on a la délégitimation d'acteurs politiques en utilisant le vocabulaire du genre.
On va par exemple féminiser des acteurs politiques qu'on n'apprécie pas. Léon Blum a vécu ça, d'autres acteurs politiques ont vécu ça.
De la même manière aussi, on va souvent féminiser les Juifs. On va les présenter comme des personnages efféminés.
Et donc là, on voit des articulations où le langage du genre permet de nuire à la réputation, la légitimité d'acteurs, même si ce qui était en jeu n'était pas nécessairement le genre en tant que tel.
Donc ça, c'est, voilà, c'est la question de l'attaque, par exemple, de Viktor Orbán sur les institutions universitaires.
Mais donc pour revenir sur la question plus large de, voilà, la crise de la démocratie et en quoi les... voilà, quel est le lien exactement que vous faites ?
Est-ce que par exemple, les personnes qui vont manifester contre le mariage pour tous en 2013 sont en fait des personnes qui sont frustrées par la démocratie ?
Ou bien est-ce que... parce que
j'ai l'impression qu'il y avait là-dedans pas mal de personnes justement assez privilégiées qui n'étaient pas vraiment blessées par le système en place, à part peut-être, voilà, sur la question du mariage pour tous.
Mais donc, j'aimerais réconcilier, voilà, ces deux idées-là.
Dans les gens qui soutiennent ce genre de discours, y a vraiment des discours extrêmement différents et des profils extrêmement différents.
Donc effectivement, la Manif pour tous, l'image principale qu'on avait, c'était l'image de bourgeois catholiques privilégiés qui-
Entre autres choses, ouais
...voilà, mais c'est volontairement une image stéréotypée, mais c'est ce qui est souvent transparu.
Et dans ce contexte-là, ben on a un refus, on a une limitation de la démocratie, c'est-à-dire de refuser d'étendre certains droits, de refuser,
par exemple, c'est aussi plus largement sur la liberté religieuse, c'est refuser une certaine laïcité de l'État, le fait que certains droits ne sont pas liés à des positions confessionnelles, des choses comme ça.
Mais après, on a des articulations suivant les pays, suivant les contextes les plus larges. Par exemple, le soutien ouvrier à l'extrême droite en France serait un autre exemple, mais qui peut s'articuler là-dedans.
Et à ce niveau-là, c'est ce qu'on a beaucoup dans les travaux sur le populisme, c'est cette idée que le populisme va aussi séduire.
Y a plusieurs, je pense, clés d'analyse.
Au niveau du soutien populaire, on a aussi un soutien de gens désabusés, de gens qui parfois, dans un monde qui est en changement permanent, peuvent être nostalgiques d'une époque où tout semblait simple.
Par exemple, l'époque où les hommes étaient des hommes et les femmes étaient des femmes, c'était beaucoup plus simple parce que maintenant, on ne sait plus.
Ça peut aussi donner une impression de stabilité face à un monde qui change beaucoup ou où tout va très vite. Eh ben là, on a des choses qui paraissent ne jamais changer. C'est faux, ça a toujours changé, mais ça donne cette illusion-là.
Il y avait déjà la transidentité-
Exactement
...au Moyen Âge.
Exactement. Mais par contre, ça donne une illusion de stabilité, de nature, l'idée que la nature avec un grand N serait quelque chose de stable, d'immuable, etc.
Donc ça peut rassurer, ça peut venir articuler ces discours nostalgiques, ces discours populistes. Ça sert aussi à délégitimer des acteurs, c'est-à-dire, on a l'impression qu'on ne s'occupe pas des vraies questions.
On s'occupe que des questions de minorités privilégiées, mais on ne s'occupe pas de la question sociale, on ne s'occupe pas de pauvreté, par exemple.
Donc voilà, ça, c'est des cartes qu'on peut jouer de manière assez importante. Ça, c'est plutôt pour les gens qui soutiennent.
Après, les gens qui organisent ces campagnes, et ce qui est important, c'est vraiment de comprendre qu'y a toute une infrastructure derrière ces campagnes.
Elles ne tombent pas du ciel. Y a des gens qui les ont inventées, qui les diffusent, qui les font fonctionner. Ce sont en général des gens assez privilégiés.
Par exemple, une des organisations anti-genre les plus connues, Ordo Iuris en Pologne,
est liée à un réseau, c'est une excroissance d'un réseau transnational d'origine brésilienne qui est TFP, Tradition, Famille, Propriété,
qui est une organisation qui d'abord aime une sorte de revival médiéval.
Donc on les voit avec des étendards, avec des lions. Leur logo, c'est un lion. Et ont des choses un peu... se réunissent dans une société secrète avec des costumes médiévaux, des choses comme ça.
Ce qui est intéressant, c'est que c'est une société qui puise énormément de soutien dans l'aristocratie. Donc, ils sont soutenus par des grandes familles de l'aristocratie européenne ou brésilienne.
Donc on a les Bragance, donc c'est une famille impériale du Brésil et du Portugal. On a les Hohenzollern et leur descendance variée en Allemagne.
Donc on a des liens avec des gens, là, hyper privilégiés qui vont articuler des discours pour séduire des gens qui, dans un certain nombre de cas, ne le sont pas.
Et des acteurs comme, là, un certain nombre d'acteurs aristocrates qui ont toujours été assez hostiles à la démocratie ou qui voient là une opportunité de réduire ou de transformer vers un autre type de régime politique.
On évoquait y a un instant l'exemple de Viktor Orbán en Hongrie, comme quoi il avait, voilà, fait en sorte d'exclure des universités qui seraient des usines à penser contre son idéologie.
Il a lutté contre les études de genre. Il a... politiquement, il s'est beaucoup concentré sur le cas, voilà, de la crise en Syrie, les vagues de migration, etc.
Il n'a pas tellement travaillé sur, voilà, les questions du mariage homosexuel ou la question de l'efféminisation de la société ou ce genre de choses-là,
alors que c'était quelque chose que beaucoup avait plus ou moins prédit en disant : « Voilà, c'est quelqu'un d'assez facho, donc il va certainement s'attaquer à ces communautés-là.
» Ça n'a pas tellement eu lieu. Voilà, on peut parler de ce qu'il a fait sur les études de genre. Est-ce que vous-même, vous avez des prédictions ?
Est-ce que vous voulez vous mouiller et faire un pari sur des choses qui risquent d'avoir lieu en Europe, disons, ces 10 prochaines années ?
C'est très difficile de dire ce qui va se passer. Alors, si on revenait à Viktor Orbán, donc c'est tout à fait vrai ce que diraient les collègues hongroises, c'est en fait, ça montre qu'il n'y a pas de réaction automatique.
C'est un exemple d'absence de backlash quoi.
Oui, ou en tout cas que le backlash peut exister s'il y a des acteurs qui ont intérêt à s'en emparer. Et ce que disaient les collègues hongroises, quand on a fait
la version originale, la version anglaise du livre sur les campagnes anti-genre en 2017, les deux collègues qui ont écrit le chapitre ont dit
: « Il n'y a pas encore de campagne anti-genre digne de ce nom en Hongrie, mais on peut penser qu'elles vont avoir lieu pour telle et telle raison.
» Et puis, quand on a fait un an et demi après la traduction française, elles ont dû changer leur article, qui n'a pas changé fondamentalement, mais elles ont dit
: « Les campagnes anti-genre ont commencé en Hongrie pour telle et telle raison, qui étaient les mêmes que celles pour lesquelles on s'attendait que ça ait lieu.
» Et notamment, c'est parce qu'effectivement, il avait déjà des boucs émissaires avec la crise migratoire, il avait d'autres questions dont il pouvait s'occuper
et il a gardé ça, de visiblement, de ce qu'on sait, de certaines lectures, etc., il a gardé ça dans un tiroir pour quand ça le servirait.
Et il s'en est saisi plus tard avec un calcul d'opportunité stratégique. Et donc ce genre de calcul-là, bon voilà, c'est pas automatique.
Après, sur ce qui peut arriver en Europe,
ce qui est clair, y a quelques années, y avait un moment de grand découragement de la part des acteurs progressistes, que ce soit au niveau politique, au niveau associatif, en disant : « C'est la fin de tout, on va...
» Ça, je pense, c'est imprévisible, on ne sait pas. Et cet état de désespoir, d'une certaine manière, était vraiment lié pour beaucoup d'acteurs à l'effet de surprise.
C'est-à-dire pendant des années, ces acteurs avaient cru qu'on était dans une espèce de progrès linéaire, de l'idée que les sociétés vont nécessairement évoluer vers plus d'égalité.
Ce qui était par exemple confirmé par un certain nombre de démographes ou de sociologues qui disaient : « Ben oui, ben regardez, les jeunes sont beaucoup plus ouverts que les vieux.
» Donc si on fait un calcul un peu réducteur, ben à partir du moment où les personnes âgées disparaissent, ben la société devrait devenir plus progressive.
L'idée que ce conservatisme est temporaire, que-
Voilà
...il est voué à disparaître d'ici quelques générations.
Et ce calcul est faux puisqu'on s'est rendu compte que les conservateurs se reproduisent.
Oui, y a des jeunes dans la Manif par exemple.
Voilà. Y a beaucoup de jeunes et y a à la fois beaucoup de jeunes dans tous ces mouvements-là. Donc y a un vrai vivier de gens qui se mobilisent, qui se forment.
Et par ailleurs, les acteurs anti-genre ont développé des institutions pour former. Donc on a des académies, des formations, on a même des universités.
Donc y a l'université de Marion Maréchal à Lyon. Ordo Iuris en Pologne vient de créer une nouvelle université, le Collegium Intermarium.
Donc on a des exemples d'institutions conservatrices pour former. Voilà. Donc tout ça pour dire qu'on ne sait pas si l'avenir sera conservateur.
Par contre, ce que je pense qui est clair, c'est qu'on aura un avenir qui sera beaucoup plus contesté. C'est-à-dire dans le temps,
y avait cette idée en Europe, effectivement, y avait peu de résistance si on compare aux États-Unis et on a eu beaucoup d'avancées dans le domaine du genre ou de la sexualité aussi parce qu'y avait pas d'opposition.
Aujourd'hui, ce qui a changé, c'est qu'on rentre probablement dans un scénario comme aux États-Unis, où y a une droite chrétienne très organisée depuis au moins 40 ans.
Et donc quand il y a des avancées comme ça, on le voit aujourd'hui, le droit à l'avortement sera peut-être bientôt perdu aux États-Unis, on attend tout le débat à la Cour suprême.
Eh bien, ce sont des stratégies construites sur plusieurs dizaines d'années où on a des acteurs, 'fin progressistes et conservateurs qui s'affrontent depuis des années
avec en gros les mêmes types d'outils, avec donc hyper professionnalisés, et cetera, des stratégies juridiques.
Personne ne connaît l'issue. Et peut-être qu'y aura un retour en arrière par rapport à ce droit. Quelque chose qui en Europe était inimaginable y a quelques années.
Et aujourd'hui, on a vu le développement d'une infrastructure qui permet à ces acteurs conservateurs de rêver peut-être un jour obtenir de telles réussites.
Donc ça, c'est la question avec un grand point d'interrogation et surtout quand on voit l'arrivée au pouvoir seul ou en coalition d'un certain nombre d'acteurs de droite ou d'extrême droite, eh bien on peut monnayer.
On peut soit réaliser son agenda, soit monnayer en échange de. Et on le voit par exemple, c'est ce qu'essaye de faire Vox en Espagne.
Vox est nécessaire à des majorités dans la région de Madrid, en Andalousie, dans la région de Murcie, et cetera. Et donc Vox monnaie ses voix à un silence sur certaines questions,
au fait qu'on ne mette plus de drapeau arc-en-ciel à la mairie de Madrid, au fait d'un certain nombre de choses qui sont exigées en échange de.
Et donc ces acteurs progressivement arrivent à obtenir des choses.
Les acteurs politiques qui arrivent au pouvoir, c'est une chose, ça, tout ça prend aussi racine dans un terreau médiatique.
Et je pense par exemple à la situation en France où on entend beaucoup de critiques. Alors, ils ont inventé, ils ont francisé le mot et moi ça m'énerve très fort, mais le wokisme,
donc qui est régulièrement pointé du doigt principalement donc sur CNews, qui est donc financé par-
Bolloré
...Bolloré, Vincent Bolloré, qui est lui-même plus ou moins en train de financer la campagne d'Éric Zemmour, donc plutôt l'extrême droite.
Donc, voilà, tentative d'essayer de reproduire un Fox News dans le paysage médiatique français. Est-ce qu'il se passe quelque chose dans les médias en Europe ?
Puisque j'ai l'impression que ces discours conservateurs-là, anti-genre, ont une certaine légitimité, sont reçus comme étant finalement très raisonnables, très, voilà, ils ont leur place.
Inversement, les discours féministes vont être pointés du doigt comme étant radicaux, exagérés, hystériques, ainsi de suite.
Est-ce qu'on est dans un schéma médiatique qui reproduit finalement une hiérarchie de pouvoir ?
Comment est-ce que vous le voyez ?
En tout cas, y a une évolution. Donc je pense qu'il manque de recherches aujourd'hui. Donc y a des projets qui sont en train d'être lancés pour essayer de comprendre ce qui se passe.
Ce qui est important, le cas français est emblématique et on est plus en cours, on le suit plus en Belgique francophone, mais il est loin d'être isolé.
On a les mêmes discours aux Pays-Bas, on a le même discours en fait en Grande-Bretagne aujourd'hui, en Pologne ou dans plein de pays en Europe.
Et ça ressemble assez fort à ce qui s'est passé déjà depuis longtemps aux États-Unis, notamment dans le giron de la droite aux États-Unis qui a investi beaucoup les espaces médiatiques,
les espaces de production d'idées, tous les think tanks,
pour développer ce genre de choses.
Et avant le woke, le woke a l'air d'être, le woke ou la cancel culture,
la dernière variante de choses plus anciennes qui ont été le politiquement correct, qui ont été le marxisme culturel ou d'autres catégories du même genre qui depuis 20 ans, 30 ans, reviennent régulièrement.
En comprenant bien les logiques médiatiques, et surtout aujourd'hui, c'est-à-dire que plus on a un point de vue outrancier, plus on a des possibilités d'être présent dans les médias.
C'est ce qui a par exemple permis à la Manif pour tous, qui était un acteur ridiculement petit en 2012, de devenir grand.
Les médias français ont cherché des gens qui s'opposaient au mariage. Y en avait pas beaucoup en réalité.
Parce qu'il fallait journalistiquement entendre les-
Voilà, ce qui est un point de vue absurde, mais parce que c'est pas parce qu'on met deux points de vue outranciers ensemble qu'on est modéré ou neutre.
Au contraire, on favorise juste des idées absurdes. Mais donc la Manif pour tous est entrée dans ce sillon-là, a bien compris comment ça se passait et est devenue un acteur aujourd'hui toujours important dans le paysage français.
Et on voit ce mécanisme à l'œuvre plus largement que les questions de genre sur tous les débats autour du woke, cancel culture, mais qui permettent des liens très clairs avec les questions raciales, avec les questions coloniales,
donc avec un certain nombre d'autres enjeux qui dépassent largement celui du genre.
Et ce qu'on voit, c'est une offensive qui contribue à une légitimation d'idées, c'est-à-dire des idées qui étaient des idées parfois
vraiment minoritaires ou des idées 'fin tellement radicales et extrêmes qu'elles étaient assez isolées.
Grand remplacement, c'est une idée, c'est un exemple. Aujourd'hui, le grand remplacement a pignon sur rue. C'est une idée loufoque,
mais qui a une légitimité, qu'on entend régulièrement, qui est répétée par plein d'acteurs et qui donc acquiert un certain statut de vérité,
un certain statut de réalité.
C'est-à-dire la répétition fait que ces choses deviennent vraies même si elles sont fausses, d'une certaine manière.
En même temps, c'est très compliqué pour les médias puisque c'est des choses qui, voilà, prennent un terreau aussi également sur les réseaux sociaux qui se développent, et cetera.
Et puis les médias ne peuvent pas adopter une position, dire : « On ne va même pas évoquer cette idée », alors que la population a peut-être des atomes crochus avec ces idées-là et ces questions se développent, et cetera.
Y a l'idée de dire : « Mais on va présenter cette idée-là pour peut-être la débunker, la contrer ou pas », dans le cadre de certaines chaînes de télévision françaises.
Mais oui, c'est une question qui est évidemment toujours très compliquée.
Mais la question, j'pense, le travail, c'est ce qu'on avait voulu faire quand on a commencé à travailler sur les campagnes anti-genre.
On voyait cette chose-là dans les débats. On se demandait : « Mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ce truc ? D'où ça vient ? » Et donc on a essayé de comprendre comment ça a été produit, qui les a produits, comment ça s'est diffusé, et cetera.
Donc j'pense c'est le même travail qui est nécessaire aujourd'hui sur les débats de cancel culture, le woke. Et là, les médias peuvent jouer un rôle important.
Parce que j'pense que le problème dans les médias, c'est d'une part de répéter tout ce qui se trouve sur les réseaux sociaux comme si... Enfin-
Mhm
...l'impression qu'y a des journalistes qui, parfois contraints par les contraintes du métier, les notamment contraintes financières, passent leur vie à répéter ce qui est sur Twitter plus qu'à faire du journalisme.
Et ce que je dis toujours dans ces cas-là, c'est si on vous dit : « Il pleut »,
la manière de faire son travail comme journaliste ou comme chercheur, c'est pas d'inviter quelqu'un qui dit : « Il ne pleut pas » pour avoir des opinions modérées.
C'est d'ouvrir la fenêtre, de mettre la main dehors et de voir si effectivement il pleut. Alors ça, c'est un exemple très simple.
Toutes les questions ne sont pas aussi simples, mais c'est pas la multiplication de points de vue qui souvent sont construits comme étant ridiculement outranciers par des gens qui ont bien compris les logiques médiatiques,
qu'on arrive à une position modérée.
Parce que sinon, il suffit de dire n'importe quoi pour atterrir dans les médias. Et y a cette... je caricature à l'extrême, mais pour que ce soit clair,
y a cette dynamique-là qui se construit aujourd'hui dans certains médias et quelqu'un comme Zemmour le fait depuis longtemps avec brio.
Il raconte strictement n'importe quoi, mais ça marche. Et par contre, ça oblige les autres personnes à se justifier sur des choses qui sont parfois très établies comme étant fausses.
Et tout d'un coup, on est obligé de battre en touche. Et donc ces acteurs conservateurs balisent le débat. On l'a vu sur le genre à l'époque.
Quand on a fait le colloque À Bemous Gender, on l'a fait parce qu'en Belgique, on n'était pas... une des raisons, c'est qu'on n'était pas attaqué, donc on pouvait réfléchir, on avait la liberté et la distance pour réfléchir.
Les collègues français qui étaient tout le temps attaqués devaient dire : « Mais non, la théorie du genre, ça n'existe pas.
» Le problème, c'est qu'y a une dynamique très performative qui fait qu'en disant que ça n'existe pas, en fait, on confirme qu'y a quand même quelque chose qui existe.
Et on accepte les termes du débat qui sont posés par ces acteurs. Et c'est ça le piège qui est très très difficile à résoudre.
J'pense que personne n'a la solution de comment en sortir, sinon on en serait déjà sorti, mais qui implique de la prudence dans les stratégies médiatiques ou académiques.
Ouais. Alors, on approche tout doucement de la fin de cet entretien. Est-ce que vous avez envie de conclure sur-
Ben ce que j'dirais sur, par exemple, ce dont on a discuté avec Backlash ou avec la crise démocratique, c'est de voir à la fois y a des enjeux qui sont de l'ordre du genre,
de l'ordre du genre dans les deux sens, c'est-à-dire à la fois sur les thèmes de genre et de sexualité, mais aussi du genre comme système social, c'est-à-dire comment est-ce que
les sociétés organisent les rapports entre les hommes et les femmes, entre les sexualités, etc.
Et y a ça qui se joue aujourd'hui. Mais c'est aussi de comprendre que y a des dimensions plus larges, c'est-à-dire de voir aussi la centralité des questions de genre et de sexualité
pour penser l'organisation de la société plus généralement, pour penser les inégalités, les rapports de pouvoir.
Et c'est pour ça aussi que les campagnes anti-genre sont plus larges, sont inversant de remises en cause plus générales.
Et là, le woke ou la cancel culture sont intéressantes.
C'est-à-dire que ce sont les mêmes acteurs qui
vont attaquer les critiques décoloniales, qui vont attaquer le travail historique pour essayer de comprendre l'héritage colonial ou
qui vont attaquer la notion de race en disant : « Ça n'existe pas », mais en refusant aussi d'aborder les questions de racisme qui,
elles, existent réellement.
Et donc là, ça permet d'élargir et de comprendre aussi qu'y a des mécanismes qui sont les mêmes, y a des acteurs qui sont les mêmes et qu'on est aujourd'hui dans un faisceau
plus inquiétant et plus large de questions et de remises en cause de la démocratie telle qu'on l'a connue au cours des 50 dernières années en Europe.
Absolument fascinant. Merci beaucoup David Paternotte pour ces 70 minutes. Est-ce qu'il y a un endroit où les auditeurs et les auditrices peuvent vous retrouver, vous lire,
une éventuelle conférence, un éventuel livre que vous publieriez, quelque chose ?
Alors, le plus facile, c'est de consulter les sites Internet à l'ULB qui sont remis à jour. Donc le plus évident pour ça, ce serait le site de l'Atelier Genre et Sexualité.
Donc si on tape dans Google ou dans un autre moteur de recherche—
Je mettrai le lien alors en description.
Et alors là, vous aurez toutes les actualités, à la fois les miennes, mais aussi celles de toute l'équipe avec laquelle je travaille.
C'est parfait. Merci beaucoup.
Merci beaucoup.
Et on se retrouve alors dans deux semaines. Au revoir. Voilà, j'espère que ça vous a plu. David Paternotte n'est pas sur les réseaux sociaux, mais comme promis, j'ai mis en description un lien vers la page de l'Atelier Genre et Sexualité de l'ULB.
J'avais sorti il y a quelques mois un édito où je vous parlais en tête-à-tête. Je revenais sur le podcast et aussi un peu sur ma petite vie.
Vous aviez été nombreux à me dire que ça vous avait beaucoup plu. J'avoue que je ne m'y attendais pas, donc c'est plutôt cool.
Je vais sans doute refaire ça dans quelques mois. Ce sera sûrement l'occasion de vous parler du harcèlement que j'ai subi suite à la publication de l'épisode avec Myriam Leroy, voilà, 'fin, fin l'année dernière.
Peut-être parler d'anxiété aussi, on verra.
Dans cet édito, j'avais aussi parlé de tous les sujets qui attirent mon attention en ce moment
et je suis très content de vous confirmer qu'incessamment sous peu vont sortir comme promis des épisodes sur les sujets comme les troubles du comportement alimentaire, la psychophobie, la schizophrénie ainsi que l'antisémitisme.
Des sujets absolument joyeux, je sais. N'oubliez pas que je donne une formation en podcast journalistique en avril.
Donc cliquez sur le lien en description. Ça va être l'occasion de se voir en vrai et de parler de ce que je fais avec Septante Minutes Avec.
On se retrouve dans deux semaines. À très bientôt.